[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue pour terminer la semaine en
beauté deux invités dont le talent est
exceptionnel mais vous le savez car ils
sont les habitués de point de vue
bonsoir fraga nazis arrive vous êtes
analyste en politiques publiques
ali rêve qui est un think tank libéral
vous êtes aussi le délégué général de
l'académie des sciences humaines et puis
comme souvent en face de vous guillaume
bernard et la bonsoir vous êtes maître
de conférences à l'institut catholique
d'études supérieures et vous sortez un
nouveau livre oui l'empereur et les
brigands ces deux nouvelles éditions
latines alors en bon français vous avez
une minute pour nous faire le pitch de
ce livre si vous le voulez bien
eh bien écoutez c'est un ouvrage que
j'ai coécrit avec corentin système l'air
qui est un jeune auteur de spectacle et
donc c'est une pièce de théâtre c'est un
ouvrage qui a été écrit sous forme d'un
dialogue entre napoléon et le lecteur le
lecteur pouvant être interprété aussi
bien comme la conscience de napoléon ou
le jugement de l'histoire et puis le
titre se justifie l'empereur et les
brigands parce que les brigands ce sont
les brigands de la vendée on s'est
interrogé sur quelle était la véritable
position de de bonaparte et de napoléon
sur la vendée sur la révolte vendéenne
sur cette dissidence
pourquoi at il voulu faire la paix
religieuse que personne n'avait réussi à
faire avant lui donc c'est un c'est une
pièce de théâtre mais c'est aussi un
spectacle puisque tout est prêt pour
pouvoir faire des vidéos projections
mettre de la musique
avis aux producteurs voilà ces formules
dès qu'on pourra se retrouver dans des
théâtres exactement ce sera possible je
propose de commencer cette émission avec
un sujet grave ce n'est pas la première
loi sur le sujet loin de là exactement
ce n'est pas la première proposition de
loi sur le sujet puisqu'elle est
d'origine parlementaire
c'est olivier falorni ancien député va
député anciennement socialistes qui la
soumet à l'assemblée une loi légalisant
l'euthanasie alors là que cette
proposition de loi a déjà été adoptée en
commission et elle sera présentée en
séance publique la semaine prochaine
que dit elle est bien elle garantit à
chacun le droit à une fin de vie
bré choisi et à une assistance
médicalisée pour mourir par une aide
active et c'est évidemment ça le mot le
plus important toute personne capable en
phase avancée ou terminale d'une
affection grave et incurable peut
demander une assistance médicalisée pour
mourir par une aide active
cette proposition de loi suscite des
réactions très diverses regarder ce
tweet de marie de hennezel qui connaît
bien ce sujet et qui s'indignent qu'on
vote l'euthanasie comme réponse à
l'indignité des fins de vie voilà la
réponse dit elle dans marche aux
nécessaires réformes proposées par le
grand âge
évidemment dit elle pour le regretter
cela coûtera moins cher je vous propose
d'écouter maintenant deux prises de
position de parlementaire en commission
par l'assemblée nationale d'abord celle
de marine brenier députés les
républicains des alpes maritimes elle
est favorable à cette loi
nous avons une opportunité historique
d'offrir l'ultime liberté de choisir sa
mort pour des malades en extrême
souffrance
certains diront que le moment est mal
choisi l'argument n'est pas entendable
pour ceux qui malades attendent
désespérément ce droit dans le pays des
droits de l'homme
et puis voici maintenant un député qui
est contre cette proposition doit il est
député en marche ce qui montre bien que
les étiquettes politiques n'ont pas
grand chose à voir avec les convictions
de chacun en tout cas qu'elle ne se
recoupent pas il est député en marche de
la charente
il est aussi médecin même pas être
renvoyés à la condition de médecins mais
pour le coup je me souviens assez bien
du serment que j'ai prononcé un serment
qui a été revu par l'ordre des médecins
en 2012 et qui prend en considération la
situation l'éthique la culture de notre
temps et qui dit je ferai tout pour
soulager les souffrances je ne
prolongerai pas abusivement les agonies
je ne provoquerai jamais la mort
délibérément on voit bien ici que la
proposition de loi qui est proposée va à
l'encontre du serment d'hippocrate
alors ce qu'il faut préciser c'est que
le gouvernement est pas du tout
enthousiaste à l'idée de
d'adopter une loi sur ce sujet guillaume
berlin il ya des oppositions de
calendrier en disant que c'est pas le
moment en pleine pandémie où nous
explique qu'il faut sauver des vies mais
il ya aussi d opposition de fond à une
telle proposition doit donc qui
légaliserait le suicide assisté
quel est votre votre point de vue alors
moi évidemment ce sont les raisons de
fond qui m'intéresse le plus même si
évidemment ça peut paraître très
paradoxal de vouloir à tout prix sauver
les personnes en ehpad et de l'autre
côté
effectivement nous dire que on peut
liquider et d'une certaine manière
légaliser légaliser le l'homicide parce
que il y à des questions de fond qui
sont quand même extrêmement importante
et je voudrais les traiter en rappelant
que dans tous les sujets liés aux
questions sociétales aux questions de
bioéthique aux questions de la morale on
a toujours des avancées petit pas par
petit pas c'est à dire que on a bien vu
qu'il y avait eu des lois qui avait été
votée pour limiter le supposé
acharnement thérapeutique
et puis ensuite on est arrivé on en est
arrivé au fait que et bien on a accepté
qu'on liquide véritablement vincent
lambert semblé avancer ce n'est pas les
associations favorables dans votre
bouche chine on est bien d'accord on est
bien d'accord mais cessez de les avancer
au sens du progressisme alors le fond du
problème
d'abord est ce que on dispose
véritablement de sa vie fergane va
naturellement développé cet argumentaire
là mais je crois que il faut poser la
question à partir du moment où on ne se
donne pas à soi-même la vie est bien
effectivement on dispose certes d'une
capacité mais pas d'une mais pas d'un
droit
d'une certaine manière sur sa propre vie
ensuite il ya un deuxième aspect des
choses qui est que il ya la capacité de
se suicider et on nous dit mais
certaines personnes qui n'ont pas les
forces physiques pour pouvoir le faire
doivent obtenir la possibilité qu'une
autre personne qu'une tierce personne
puisse effectivement les tuer ça
voudrait dire que le consentement
deviendrait la légitimation et bien d'un
homicide parce que transférer à un tiers
la possibilité
d'éliminer une personne c'est légaliser
l'avortement le quel lapsus c'est
légaliser effectivement le l'homicide
est celle égaliser cet homicide
sous prétexte qu'il y aurait le
consentement de la victime dont je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui est
parfaitement discutable et en tout cas
pour ma part j'y suis farouchement
opposé ferghana diaries guillaume erner
un petit peu de vent c'est mon
argumentaire effectivement moi je
m'inscris dans une tradition
philosophique qui estime que l'homme est
propriétaire de sa personne de sa vie de
ses biens c'est la tradition qui nous
vient de john locke tradition libérale
et l'homme est un propriétaire de sa vie
de sa personne de ses biens il peut en
disposer comme bon lui semble tant
qu'ils ne portent pas atteinte
effectivement à la personne aux biens ou
à la vie d'autrui donc je ne vois pour
ma part aucune objection mort à la
légalisation du suicide assisté ne veut
pas dire qu'il faille encourager les
gens à se suicider ce qui ne veut pas
dire que nous sommes pas légitime à
dissuader quelqu'un qui voudrait en fait
ni en descente de l'aude de le raisonner
en essayant de me convaincre que la vie
mérite d'être vécue quelles que soient
les épreuves mais je trouve qu'il est
cynique il me rallie injuste de
prétendre se substituer au choix des
principaux intéressés et que la décision
doit en dernier ressort revenir
simplement aux patients donc oui
guillaume bernard seux se désole que le
consentement puisse ici être la source
d'une obligation juridique ou plutôt de
de la possibilité d'un suicide assisté
moi je m'inscris dans une tradition qui
pense que nous consommons doit être en
effet la source de toute obligation tout
court donc ça ne me ça me paraît être la
moindre des choses en effet qu'on
reconnaît c'est qu'on autorise pas mais
qu'on reconnaisse ce droit antérieur à
la société de l'homme a disposé de sa
vie comme comme bon 800 même si encore
une fois le suicide assisté n'est pas
l'obligation
mourir n'est pas l'eau médiation de deux
de tuer quelqu'un ce n'est qu un choix
qui peut être actionné ou non tout
simplement le problème si vous voulez
c'est que l'on met le doigt sur un vrai
problème de philosophie du droit qui est
la question de savoir est ce que parce
que l'on en a une faculté on dispose du
droit d'exercer cette faculté et les
modernes dont fait partie le la pensée
libérale considère que parce que je
dispose d'une faculté ou parce qu'il
faut que l'on me reconnaisse une faculté
de faire quelque chose je dispose d'un
droit à faire cette chose là
et puis il ya les classiques c'est
aristote c'est saint thomas d'aquin qui
considère que pour qu'il y ait une
relation juridique pour qu'ils aient une
relation de droit il faut qu'ils aient
une relation d'altérité ses vis-à-vis de
l'autre effectivement je suis
susceptible que l'on me reconnaisse un
droit
autrement dit ça signifie que pour les
classiques pour la pensée classique qui
n'est pas nécessairement d'ailleurs une
pensée chrétienne qui peut être une
pensée chrétienne et pas nécessairement
chrétienne et bien on ne dispose pas
d'un droit sur soi même
personne évidemment ne va contester le
fait qu'une personne si elle tient à
tout prix à se suicider je peux le
regretter
moralement mais elle va effectivement en
avoir la capacité de le faire
pour autant lui reconnaître le droit de
se suicider et donc par conséquent le
fait de pouvoir exiger que si elle n'a
pas la capacité
eh bien elle doit obtenir qu'un autre la
suicide ça en revanche c'est
parfaitement discutable et je fais
partie de ceux qui s'y opposent est-ce
que je peux juste rebondir souligne
guillaume parce que je trouve que
l'argument est un peu pernicieux c'est à
dire que lorsque vous dites que on ne
dispose pas d'un droit sur soi même
c'est quand même un argument qui pose
problème parce que la nature ayant
horreur du vide si je n'ai pas de droit
sur moi même c'est que quelqu'un donne
un endroit sûr que 6 mai jusque inscrire
qu'interdire à l'état interdit à part
donc en l'état interdit à quelqu'un de
se suicider de fait il délègue un
magistrat un policier le pouvoir de
disposer de la personne de quelqu'un
contre son gré ce qui revient en fait à
reconnaître une forme d'esclavagé
rappelé site puisque
ou bien je suis propriétaire de moi même
ou bien à société est propriétaire de
moi non ce sont deux oppositions qui
sont fait rire un conseiller en fait
vous partez du principe que toutes les
relations sociales peuvent être jury 10
6 et ça c'est un postulat de la
modernité qui dit que l'homme en tant qu
il est un homme dispose de droits
intrinsèquement le droit dans la pensée
classique mais non c'est le droit du
juste naturalisme moderne le droit tel
qu'il est pensé par les classiques tels
que vous pouvez l'analyse et où le voir
par exemple chez aristote tout saint
thomas d'aquin ou plus récemment chez
michel villey et bien le droit c'est une
rétribution d'un acte c'est un pouvoir
c'est une fonction c'est une
c'est une de liberté c'est un honneur
que l'on se voit attribuer en raison de
l'eau dure d'un rôle que l'on remplit
autrement dit on ne récompense pas mais
autrement dit il n'y a pas de droit sur
soi même on a un pouvoir de disposer de
soi mais on ne dispose pas d'un droit
opposable à une autre personne de
d'exiger que l'on soit suicidé si bien
par un droit criant mais ça d'obliger il
s'agit pas d'obliger le médecin a le
bétail de refuser mais vous savez bien
que c'est ce à quoi cela va aboutir
et de fait sous le feu des locaux a eu
mais le fait de revendiquer le suicide
assisté sous prétexte qu'une personne ne
peut pas elle même se suicider et bien
c'est de fait
exiger d'un tiers que et bien son
consentement justifient ou l'homicide et
que du coup il se serait une cause
exonératoire de responsabilité je vous
de voir les points de vue de nos
internautes qui eux aussi débattent avec
des arguments
passionnant l'état nazi est un sujet
très sensible ou dit micheline il faut
vraiment y réfléchir
et si cela se fait former du personnel
préparer le corps médical pour beaucoup
c'est là peut-être choquant mais ajoute
elle quand la souffrance est
insupportable accompagner une personne à
franchir le pas doit être mûrement
réfléchie et préparée antoine sur
twitter dîner à quoi cela sert-il
d'ériger la santé au dessus de tout si
c'est pour autoriser un médecin a tué
son patient dominique sur youtube mourir
dans la dignité quelle horreur on ferait
mieux de s'occuper de nos anciens plutôt
que de les assassiner le mot est fort il
est immoral de laisser quelqu'un se
suicider nous vous posons la question
sur twitter est ce le bon moment pour
légaliser l'euthanasie et la réponse est
oui à 65%
ce n'est pas un sondage mais l'opinion
française est favorable semble-t-il
d'après les enquêtes à une évolution de
la législation sur ce sujet écoutez le
directeur général adjoint de l'ifop
frédéric dabi qui réagissait sur ce
sujet normand dans des enquêtes
d'opinion
autant de décalage entre ce que
proposait pouvoirs publics
est ce que demande ce que souhaitent des
français depuis maintenant dix quinze
ans depuis la faire face à ambert
systématiquement quelle que soit la
manière de poser la question quelle que
soit la méthodologie les français dans
leur très forte majorité appellent de
leurs voeux une légalisation du suicide
assisté la possibilité de recourir dans
certains cas à des euthanasies cette
attente est d'autant plus forte qu'elle
est massive peu de clivage générationnel
pas de clivage de genres très peu de
clivage poli très peu de clivages
politiques
est ce que guillaume bardin ça n'est pas
un argument ça important s'il ya une
majorité qui souhaitent une évolution de
la loi alors je vais vous dire la même
chose que ce que vous a dit ici même
mercredi dernier jérôme sainte marie
émission excellente que j'ai écouté très
attentivement en vous disant que l'on
peut obtenir si l'on veut des résultats
à un sondage en posant les questions
d'une certaine manière
évidemment si vous dites est ce qu'une
personne l'y aiderez malades qui
souffrent beaucoup
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas lui offrir
la possibilité de mourir dans la dignité
qui naturellement est réduite aux
aspects exclusivement matériels soit dit
en passant
bon évidemment vous obtenez 90% de
réponse oui si en revanche vous poser la
question en offrant un certain nombre de
possibilités notamment en ouvrant la
possibilité d des soins palliatifs et
bien vous obtenez une majorité qui est
beaucoup moins grande et vous obtenez
grosso modo environ 50% des français et
ces enquêtes ont été faites par l'ifop
d'ailleurs 50 % des français sont serait
plutôt favorable
effectivement une forme d'euthanasie
mais l'autre moitié des français sont
avant tout favorable à ce que l'on
favorise les soins palliatifs qui
permettrait à une personne en fin de vie
de ne pas et bien activer la mort ou
faire activer la mort mais de prendre le
temps effectivement de régler ses
comptes avec sa famille de partir dans
la paix et pourquoi pas de préparer la
vie d'après quid du patient car
justement des soins palliatifs c'est ça
mais n'est ce pas au patient encore une
fois d'avoir le dernier mot moi je suis
toujours assez sceptique quand on
convoque la majorité comme si elles
étaient légitimes va statuer sur ce qui
ne la regarderai sur ce qui ne la
regarde pas est ce que ce n'est pas au
principal intéressé de dire je veux
continuer les soins palliatifs où je
veux en finir ici
mais le problème pardon fergane le
problème c'est que qu'une personne se
suicide moi je le réprouvent moralement
mais je ne peux pas l'empêcher de le
faire mais qu'en revanche l x
ij d'obtenir a droit lui permettant de
revendiquer que d'autres là dessus ça en
revanche cette transmission d'un droit
c'est encore une fois ce n'est pas une
crise existe avec gaza il existait déjà
une loi sur ce sujet elle date de 2016
c'est la loi claisse leonetti et elle
autorise le médecin ferghana ziari a
pratiqué dans certaines conditions une
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès c'est à dire en fait de deux
plongées la personne dans le coma dans
le coma mais jusqu'à la mort c'est à
dire que ce n'est pas une aide active
mais est ce que vous considérez pas que
on atteint avec ce type de possibilités
un juste équilibre dans pour vous il
faut aller plus loin
non je pense qu'il faut être cohérent
avec le principe de libre disposition de
soi même si c'est un principe qu'il dit
à bernard récuse
je pense que cette loi fait dix mois une
forme de compromis
voilà électorale pour ne pas trop
titiller les festivités conservatrice
d'une certaine population que je regarde
mais en effet sur le principe si on est
rigoureux et bien il faudrait
reconnaître une pleine souveraineté ou à
l'individu quant au choix de sa fin de
vie et je le répète encore une fois ce
n'est pas une créance qu'on oppose à un
médecin puisque j'espère bien et si
jamais ce n'est pas le cas on sera tous
les deux d'accord pour dire qu'il ne
convient pas de contraindre les médecins
à commettre des actes qu'ils réprouvent
au nom de leur moral de leur conscience
personnelle ne s'agit pas de mettre un
point final sur la science et du
principe même de la médecine qui
consiste à soigner et pas et enfin
contre la copal malgré le patient c'est
à dire on a beaucoup parlé de pandémie
de corée de coronavirus on a beaucoup
parlé de ceux qui prennent des décisions
à la place des populations et veulent
faire notre bien malgré nous la santé
oui mais dans le consentement des
populations concernées
merci pour ces pas du très argumentée
qui vous aideront j'espère a formé le
vôtre on passe à un autre sujet plus
léger
coucou le revoilà edouard philippe
l'ancien premier ministre
des manuels macron sort la semaine
prochaine un livre qu'il a co écrit avec
un de ses conseillers qui est aussi un
de ses amis proches
gilles boyer ça s'appelle impressions et
ligne claire et c'est un livre qui
revient sur l'expérience du pouvoir tels
que la pratique et edouard philippe
lorsqu'il a été nommé premier ministre
en 2017 par emmanuel macron tout le
monde s'interroge bien sûr pourquoi est
ce que doit philippe sort un livre de ce
type at il des ambitions
veut-il faire concurrence emmanuel
macron veut-il être un recours avant
d'entendre votre point de vue je vous
propose de prendre connaissance de cet
extrait d'un interview donnée par
edouard philippe
au point de cette semaine est il assez
de phrase intéressante il dit si le
président m'avait dit qu'il fallait
gérer la crise tout en restant dans
l'esprit réformateur de 2017
je n'aurais pas refuser évidemment et il
ajoute il ne me l'a pas demandé
c'est à dire faire ghana ziari
qu'edouard philippe se pose en gardien
de la volonté réformatrice d' emmanuel
macron que celui ci aurait peut-être
abandonné en cours de route qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette lecture
écoutez je ne sais pas si il est sincère
dans sa démarche réformatrice
en revanche ce qui est certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le le jeu politique tel
qu'il existe aujourd'hui ne favorise pas
la réforme c'est à dire que sans douté
de la volonté réformatrice
emmanuel macron on constate
effectivement qu'il a complètement mises
de côté au cours de son quinquennat
parce que la crise et gilet jaune est
passé par là parce que les mentalités
françaises ne sont pas prêtes finalement
à une réforme de l'état
ce qui montre que le blocage est avant
tout culturelle et c'est là où moi je
suis toujours sceptiques vous savez par
cette ce mercato qui consiste à
s'intéresser à la personnalité de tel ou
tel homme politique je ne crois pas
qu'il soit judicieux de personnaliser
des problèmes de la france dira que même
si demain edouard philippe
avec la crédibilité la stature politique
pour accéder au pouvoir après tout
pourquoi pas des très apprécié des
français là
le précédent emmanuel macron montre très
bien qu'on peut arriver de nulle part et
en quelques années seulement accéder à
la présidence de la république
seulement il me semble que la société
française est caractérisée par des
blocages institutionnels et culturelles
qui sont beaucoup plus profond et qui
vont au delà de la personnalité des
dirigeants de sorte que même celui qui
aurait les meilleures volontés du monde
à mon avis en l'état actuel des choses
n'arriverai à rien la question est posée
sur twitter à vous tous qui nous
suivaient pensez vous qu edouard
philippe soit l'homme du recours et vous
répondez non à 65%
et puis voici deux commentaires celui
d'hervé qui considère que d'edouard
philippe c'est la même chose que macron
mais avec un emballage différents bonnet
blanc et blanc bonnet aurait-on dit au
siècle dernier alors que karina sur
twitter ne dit pour moi edouard philippe
est présidentiable et c'est celui pour
qui je voterai volontiers et vous
guillaume bardin vous verriez bien voter
pour edouard philippe vote est secret
dont vous n'êtes pas obligé de répondre
à cette question comme aux autres
d'ailleurs
vous savez que il ya de fortes chances
que mon vote soit comme mon drapeau
plutôt blanc bon mais non je dirais que
il est certain que il faut que le
positionnement de la grande coalition
macro nien pour l'instant en tout cas la
grande coalition des modérés de droite
et de gauche
il faut qu'elle soit incarnée qu'on le
veuille ou non à la présidentielle
et dans ces conditions si emmanuel
macron ne devait pas pouvoir y retourner
parce que les français rejette l'idée
d'un remake
macron le pen parce que il ya dégagisme
qui pourrait continuer et dans ces
conditions il serait assez logique que
ce soit le premier premier ministre de
cette grande coalition qui est arrivée
au pouvoir en 2010 est qu'ils puissent
reprendre le flambeau et la réincarner
bon donc objectivement edouard philippe
est parti au bon moment dans la gestion
de la crise du cosy de 19
pour ma part je n'étais pas satisfait de
ce qu'il a fait mais en tout cas
l'opinion publique au moment où il est
parti était plutôt satisfait de ce qu'il
avait fait et et la grogne commence
maintenant plus con contre castex que
contre que contre lui autrement dit il
peut effectivement apparaître comme
étant sur un positionnement de droite et
de gauche modérée de grande coalition
tout en ayant effectivement une plaie
c'est plutôt un bon souvenir dans les
dures périodes cela dit effectivement il
ya quand même la crise et gilet jaune
qui peut ressortir à n'importe quel
moment sous une forme ou sous une autre
et ce qui pourrait peut-être lui puis
pâtir mais il est certain en tout cas
que l'option qui a été fait de ne plus
avoir une droite et une gauche modérée
qui alternent au pouvoir ou qui
cohabitent mais qu'elle se réunisse pour
gouverner ensemble
ça laisse uniquement comme possibilité
si jamais eh bien elle ne perdure pas
d'elle de less than less comme
possibilité que les extrêmes donc
forcément cette grande coalition
elle devra être incarnée par macron par
un autre pourquoi pas avoir fini fini
par edouard philippe alors nadia sur
youtube de vie il faut vraiment être
désespéré pour poser cette question
j'espérais de corps ne s'est pas accro
en tout cas fait capacité peut-être à à
rebondir et à redevenir sympathique aux
français et puis il ya deux internautes
au moins qui nous rappelle le même
épisode chardon bleu sur lefigaro.fr
pour moi edouard philippe restera
l'homme hyper rigide qui a imposé les 80
km/heure et qui n'a pas été très bien
avec les gilet jaune du début et puis
nicole 06 toujours sur lefigaro.fr le 80
km/heure n'est pas oubliée on se demande
toujours ferghana ziari qu'encore un
responsable politique est associée à ce
point à une simple mesure si si c'est
abusif c'est caricatural ou bien si ça
dit quelque chose
est ce que pour vous et leurs philippe
cc c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas
libérale puisqu'il voulait à tout prix
empêcher les français dont
pour la libérale l'autre libéral avec
j'avais où c'est assez le maire-adjoint
moins pétillant personnes sur la scène
politique française est assez libérale
mais sérieux coup je ne pensais pas
vraiment ou 80 kilomètres à l'heure
quand je pense à leurs clips
en réalité je ne pense pas à grand chose
c'est à dire que un personnage qui c'est
encore pire
disons qu'il n'a pas eu le temps
vraiment d'imprégner ça ça ça marque il
a été très sympathique aux yeux au jeu
des français parce que il a une forte
personnalité il parle bien il est une
éloquence et une stature mais sur le
plan idéologique
ce n'es quelqu'un que je n'ai jamais
vraiment réussi à cerner véritablement
d'autant plus que la politique a ceci de
fâcheux qu'elle ne récompensent pas la
sincérité idéologique puisqu'il faut
toujours faire des compromis en fonction
des du moment donc et le maquereau nice
pas toujours été un en même temps qui
fait que l'identité politique de toute
cette bande à maquereau on a toujours eu
du mal à cerner elle a toujours incarné
une forme de consensus mou qui pour ne
fâcher personne risque de mécontenter
tout le monde et je crois que edouard
philippe
à moins qu'ils clarifient son discours
idéologique et bien nana ne risque pas
en tout cas d'inspirer grand chose
d'autant plus que je joue j'assiste
parce que je ne pense pas encore une
fois qu'il faille s'arrêter à la
personnalité des dirigeants vous savez
on a beaucoup parlé de cette crise
ducobu jenner de cette gestion
calamiteuse on a tous été exaspéré mais
à titre personnel je ne sais même pas si
quelqu'un aurait fait mieux aujourd'hui
parce que ce sont les règles du jeu et
qui pose problème
au delà de la personnalité de macron de
d'edouard philippe de marine le pen ou
autre je crois vraiment que le problème
français est institutionnel et que si on
continue comme ça à fantasmer sur
l'homme providentiel
on ira de déception en déception sans
comprendre que le mal est beaucoup plus
profond et qui ne s'agit pas comme ça de
modifier le cv de ce et qui soudain tête
de l'état pour espérer un changement
profond de la politique française
alors moi je suis assez d'accord sans
doute pas pour les mêmes motivations
mais de manière globale effectivement
sur le fait que le chili fier
les enjeux idéologiques pour faire des
choix pour que les français lorsqu'ils
sont amenés à voter lors d'un référendum
lors d'une élection qu'ils aient des
choix clairs à faire ça alors là en
revanche je suis je suis parfaitement
d'accord
simplement les forces politiques c'est
et de l'idéologique et du sociologique
la conséquence d'une éventuelle
candidature de d'edouard philippe à la
place emmanuel macron comme doublure
comme remplaçant la conséquence me
semble-t-il
ça serait que ça deviendrait plus
difficile à et l'air pur d'avoir un
candidat autonome
même si effectivement xavier bertrand
essaye de se droitiser ça deviendrait
plus difficile pour elles air d'avoir
une candidature oui autonome est propre
et du et par conséquent et alors là pour
le coup ça m'intéresse beaucoup ça
ouvrirait la possibilité d'une
candidature de droite hors les murs
d'une droite alternative qui pourrait
faire l'unité de la droite est là et là
ça deviendrait intéressant donc
peut-être qu'il faut pousser edouard
philippe
à vouloir remplacer emmanuel macron pour
que l'espace politique soit bien
renouveler et que le spectre politique
fait des intérêts de boutique des
actuels partie explose et que l'on ait
des nouvelles personnalités qui puisse
incarner de vrais choix idéologique
quelques réactions d'internautes celle
de fred sur youtube
l'homme du recours s'appelle vaccins
nous dit il
et puis sûrement pas ces commentaires ne
se rend pas dit guillaume barba qui
n'est pas près de se faire vacciner à
part dans et puis cette remarque de jean
marc sur youtube qu'at-il fait de
remarquables à part changer
partiellement la couleur de sa barbe
c'est vers jean-marc parce que ce pauvre
edouard philippe
je pense que c'est la pression qui a eu
sur lui lors de la gestion de la crise
du coc vide en tout cas dans sa première
partie qui a fait blanchir sa barre avec
celui ci n'y est pour rien que ce
dernier plutôt n'y est pour rien
soulevait l'hypothèse de 2
edouard philippe comme un recours mais
est ce que vous croyez pas que si
emmanuel macron n'est pas en capacité de
se représenter
c'est parce que ce qu'il incarne serait
rejetée à un point tel que l'homme qui a
gouverné avec lui la moitié du
quinquennat ne serait pas plus plus
légitime
regardez ses passes avec emmanuel à quoi
françois hollande c'est à dire que après
tout mais emmanuel macron été ministre
de françois hollande
et malgré ça il a réussi à se
désolidariser finalement du quinquennat
de françois hollande a pas apparaître
comme étant l'homme nouveau qui se
tissent inscrits en rupture avec
l'action du gouvernement dans le week
end
enfin gouvernement -qui là auxquels il a
participé donc avec un petit peu
d'habileté politique qui est d'infinis
peu peut aussi récidiver d'autant qu'il
a été débarqué aussi par emmanuel macron
donc il peut toujours au pyla d'écart
revendiqué en effet celle ce
licenciement pour ce faire pour ce faire
une qu'on appelle ça une virginité une
virginité voilà tout à fait vous y
croyez aussi que maintenant il peut
exister par lui même alors écoutez je
crois que de toute façon en politique
aujourd'hui on n'existe pas par soi même
il faut une structure il faut des
réseaux un bon en revanche ça je le
répète je le crois sincèrement la grande
coalition des forces modérées a besoin
de perdurer sans quoi c'est forcément
des forces extrêmes qui arriveront au
pouvoir donc moi j'ai été je dois vous
l'avouer étonné que ce risque soit pris
part j'allais dire entre guillemets le
système de de mettre en place la
cohabitation permanente parce que
effectivement ça signifie que si cette
cohabitation si cette grande coalition
déçoit ça veut dire que automatiquement
eh bien ce sont des forces politiques
qui sont sur les extrêmes du spectre
brics ça ne veut pas forcément dire
qu'elle soit extrémistes mais les forces
politiques qui sont sur les extrêmes du
spectre politique qui seraient
susceptibles de l'emporter
merci beaucoup il reste encore un peu
plus d'un an ça va aller très vite pour
voir si ce genre de scénario peut se
concrétiser merci beaucoup à tous les
deux merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
point de vue revient mardi prochain et
d'ici là joyeuses fêtes de pâques
[Musique]